every family is different
and that means every homeschool is gonna be different too
the beauty of homeschooling is that you get to do whatever works for your family
and of all the homeschool families you see online
no two are gonna be exactly the same
sure you might have the same resources or curriculum as someone else
but how you use them is totally unique to you
our child it's why I started sharing our homeschooling journey
but also why I started following other homeschool
I truly love seeing and learning what other people are using in their homeschool
my areas of weakness are someone else's strength
and there's so much value in watching and learning what they're doing
I am really good at creating hands on lessons
especially for math and reading
but I am terrible at history
art and music
so I tend to follow people who are posting that kind of content
because when I follow them
I'm learning from them and I'm strengthening my weaknesses